scène de rentrée ordinaire l'inscription
aux activités extra scolaires les
enfants en dessous des fonds du
badminton cette année particularité une
partie est prise en charge par la mairie
la famille bénéficier du pass for many
quoi grâce à palm os palm j'ai bénéficié
d'économie beaucoup d'économies pour
profiter à mes enfants et
beaucoup
et notre activité aussi avec le palm
c'est ça fait 45 euros et sans palme
c'est
3-4-3 plus comme je me sport surtout le
montage pourrait en faire plus que ce
que j'en fais par exemple on a fait
désirer je pense qu'on va faire
peut-être quatre heures par semaine en
clair elle la commune conclu des
partenariats avec 21 associations 2020
manille badminton accueille entre 10 et
15% de palme s'il n'ya pas le palu
peuvent pas venir c'est quand vous avez
deux ou trois enfants avec l'inscription
utah sandales qui encore néons et ans
on est un club très cher juste les
enfants passent pas le faire socialement
je trouve que c'est important pour eux
de pouvoir partager aussi avec leurs
copains d'école de venir en club le palm
existe depuis 2016 le passeport est
aujourd'hui accessible de la maternelle
à la première année de lycée sous
conditions de ressources quotient
familial de moins de 10000 euros les
populations qui n'ont vraiment pas
beaucoup de ressources échappe
totalement à la aux associations et aux
activités pour les enfants etc donc nous
avons réfléchi à tout ça nous avons
décidé non pas de donner 40 euros 60
euros pour une inscription à une
association mais de prendre en charge
l'inscription total à l'exception de 15
ou 30 ans ou 50 euros 30 euros tour
alors c'est 30 et 50 maintenant ça a
changé en 2016 70 palm avait été
demandée pour cette rentrée ce sont plus
de 300 bénéficiaires dénombrés par la
mairie de magny les hameaux